[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas si buscáis en
google información sobre la gran ciudad
de san louis missouri esto paneles con
un montón de artículos sobre su declive
y sus problemas sociales los problemas
raciales o la marginalidad para que os
hagáis una idea a día de hoy cada año
que pasa san luis pierde cerca del 1 por
ciento de su población vamos que no es
que hablemos precisamente de una de las
ciudades más pujantes de américa esta ha
sido la tendencia de los últimos seis
años y sabéis que nada indica que se vea
revertir en el corto plazo
informes sanluis la ciudad
estadounidense que más rápido se hunde
pero un momento porque san luís no
siempre fue así hablamos de la que un
día fue la ciudad más importante al
oeste del río misisipí y una de las más
ricas florecientes y con más actividad
económica de todos los estados unidos un
lugar muy próspero que además era
también uno de los hawks culturales y
artísticos más destacados del país era
una urbe mucho más grande y más
importante que alguna de las grandes
metrópolis de eeuu actualmente con
especial mención a chicago luego veréis
por qué
esta es la otra cara la cara más
desconocida de una ciudad san luís que
durante un tiempo fue uno de los lugares
más brillantes de los eeuu de américa
[Música]
san luis co fundada por los franceses en
1764 y luego en el año 1803 adquirida
por el gobierno norteamericano como
parte del acuerdo de compra de luisiana
gracias a su incorporación a la unión a
su privilegiada ubicación junto al río
misisipí y su papel como puente entre
los estados fundadores y los sureños de
1818 la ciudad se había convertido en
todo un centro de comunicaciones en gran
medida gracias a los barcos mercantes
que desde aquí surcaban las aguas del
misisipí tres años después en 1821
missouri adquirió la categoría de estado
en los años sucesivos la ciudad
experimentó una explosión de prosperidad
que multiplicó tanto su crecimiento
económico como demográfico tanto es así
que para 1860 tan sólo un siglo después
de su fundación la ciudad ya había
superado los 150 mil habitantes y en los
siguientes 10 años su población se
multiplicó de nuevo por dos hasta
superar la cifra de los 300.000
habitantes
[Música]
y amigos aunque estas cifras a ojos de
hoy puedan parecernos poca cosa podéis
creerme cuando os digo que en esa época
300 mil personas eran el equivalente hoy
a una ciudad de varios millones de
habitantes el caso es que de esta forma
la salud llegó a convertirse en uno de
los grandes centros estadounidenses de
la industria de los servicios
profesionales como por ejemplo las
finanzas o la publicidad y de hecho ocho
empresas de la lista fortune 500 todavía
están radicadas aquí sin embargo un
momento porque actualmente lo cierto es
que las cosas son muy pero que muy
diferentes por ejemplo san luís tiene la
segunda mayor tasa de delitos violentos
de todo el país tan sólo por detrás de
detroit en san luís una de cada 51
personas fueron víctimas de un delito
violento tan sólo durante el año 2020 y
de hecho en este mismo año en 2020 fue
también considerada como una de las diez
ciudades más peligrosas de todo el mundo
según el consejo ciudadano para la
seguridad pública y la justicia penal
una organización mexicana que cada año
publica un ranking con las ciudades más
violentas conforme al número de
homicidios y si san luís está entre las
diez primeras pero amigos esta urbe no
sólo comparte con detroit una ciudad
de la que por cierto ya os hablamos en
un vídeo que os dejo la descripción las
altas tasas de criminalidad sino también
las de marginalidad y exclusión racial
pero esto no este vídeo no lo vamos a
dedicar al san luís de hoy
con los datos que hemos puesto sobre la
mesa creo que todos nos podemos hacer
una idea bastante clara sobre cómo están
por aquí las cosas por eso lo que
queremos hacer en esta ocasión es
hablaros de algo un poquito diferente
algo para lo que tenemos que remontarnos
unos cuantos años atrás en el tiempo
queridos amigos en el siglo 19 dos
ciudades no demasiado lejanas competían
mano a mano por convertirse en el eje
comercial más importante una es
obviamente sanluis y la otra
chicago sin embargo mientras que chicago
es hoy una próspera megaurbe sanluis no
es más que una ciudad de tamaño medio
tirando a pequeño repleta de problemas y
que sufre altísimas tasas de abandono de
edificios y mucha muchísima delincuencia
y la pregunta es qué demonios pasó para
que san luís cayera en desgracia y
chicago se elevará a los cielos que
marcó exactamente la diferencia pues
bien descubramos lo
[Música]
pero un momento antes de continuar me
gustaría contaros una cosa
y
[Música]
y todos sabéis que la razón de ser de
visual política es dar a conocer los
sucesos que explican las noticias lo que
se esconde tras los grandes titulares de
la actualidad y para poder seguir
creciendo y mejorando vosotros sois una
parte fundamental por estar semana tras
semana justo ahí al otro lado de la
pantalla y también por la ayuda que
muchos de vosotros nos brindan en patria
un patrón que por cierto hemos puesto
patas arriba para remodelarlo y darle
vida y hacer que se convierta realmente
en un epicentro de la comunidad por eso
además de los contenidos exclusivos para
patronas que ya tenemos en marcha como
por ejemplo nuestro boletín semanal o
los vídeos editoriales lanzaremos
también encuestas y consultas periódicas
en las que por ejemplo podréis elegir
temas para futuros vídeos o hacernos
llegar vuestras preguntas además
importante también hemos preparado
productos exclusivos que nunca pondremos
a la venta serán diseños exclusivos y
únicos para patrio así que si quieres
formar parte del visor político ya
puedes hacerlo sumando te a nuestro
patrón poco a poco irá cobrando más y
más vida nos dejamos por aquí abajo toda
la información y dicho esto continuemos
[Música]
víctima de sí misma y de la mala suerte
echas un vistazo atentamente a este
gráfico
a día de hoy san luis tiene menos de 300
mil habitantes en concreto unos 294 mil
900 y en el año 1870 tenía 310 mil
espera nueva 1870 tenían más habitantes
que ahora pues y así es y no se trata de
ningún error de hecho su población
máxima se alcanzó hace ya mucho tiempo
en la década de los años 50 cuando una
ciudad superó los 850 mil habitantes
desde entonces amigos a louis ha perdido
ni más ni menos que casi el 70 por
ciento de su población y evidentemente
esta no es la evolución natural de una
ciudad ni tampoco algo frecuente es algo
extraño raro sorprendente insólito pero
para conocer las raíces de esta historia
tenemos que remontarnos hasta la década
de 1850 en ese momento san louis y
chicago dos ciudades relativamente
cercanas ambas situadas en la cuenca del
misisipí con acceso fluvial directo a
los asentamientos del medio oeste es
cuando empezaron a competir ferozmente
[Música]
en ese momento san luís era una ciudad
mucho más grande y mucho más importante
que chicago que apenas tenía 30.000
habitantes en 1850 en aquel entonces
albis era el epicentro del comercio
norte-sur un comercio que se hacía
fundamentalmente a través de barcos de
vapor a lo largo del río mississippi
si hablamos de esos famosos barcos que
instalé en las películas de época pues
bien debido a su posición geográfica
sanluis era la ciudad más norteña que
estaba conectada mediante una vía
natural directa con nueva orleans en los
estados sureños y el caribe por su parte
la pequeña chicago tenía en ese momento
nueva york como su principal socio
comercial y puerta de entrada y salida
al extranjero
pero amigos podemos decir que san luis
ha sido a lo largo de la historia una
ciudad acostumbrada a estar en el lugar
correcto pero no en el momento adecuado
o quizás mejor dicho nunca ha tenido un
escenario adecuado esta es una historia
de como el conformismo la burocracia la
falta de dinamismo y la poca ambición
acabaron con una de las grandes urbes
del mundo occidental pero no nos
desviemos el caso es que en 1948 esta
ciudad recibió su primer golpe ese año
se completó un canal que conectaba los
grandes lagos directamente con el río
misisipí que como ya sabéis es el río
que vayas a louis
y qué ciudad está situada en la orilla
de los grandes lagos del lago michigan
en concreto exacto
chicago así que ya os podéis imaginar
que este hito fue sumamente importante
para la ciudad de la judía y las pizzas
de los pisos por primera vez chicago se
situó en una posición privilegiada de
repente la pequeña ciudad al borde de
los grandes lagos tenía acceso al
comercio fluvial con el sur de eeuu y no
sólo eso además desde allí se podía
comerciar también con los territorios
del norte de la actual carnada y además
estaba mejor conectada con la costa este
sobre todo con nueva york así que tal y
como podéis suponer esto hizo que salud
y se perdiera uno de sus puntos más
fuertes ya que gracias a su enclave en
pino misisipí que era hasta entonces un
lugar único para el comercio con los
estados del sur especialmente con la
incipiente ciudad de nueva orleans donde
desemboca el mississippi claro que la
competencia nunca es un problema salvo
que no quieras enfrentarla me explico
paralelamente al desarrollo del canal se
empezaron a poner en marcha los primeros
proyectos de ferrocarriles en las dos
ciudades aunque eso sí se hizo una
velocidad muy diferente y es que veréis
en esa época se consideraba que el
ferrocarril serviría fundamentalmente
para expandir el área de influencia de
las ciudades que se habían desarrollado
gracias a vías naturales de transporte
por ejemplo el mississippi digamos que
el ferrocarril y permitía que muchos
condados pudieran acceder a las grandes
vías de transporte fluvial empujando con
ello el crecimiento de los estados y
particularmente de esas grandes ciudades
de esos grandes polos logísticos
sin embargo a pesar de ser una ciudad
mucho más grande y con muchos más
recursos que chicago sanluis sus
autoridades y sus grandes empresarios
vivían completamente volcados al
misisipí esto es lo que explica en gran
medida la mayor lentitud a la hora de
sacar adelante los proyectos
ferroviarios en cierta forma al tren se
le veía con cierto recelo por
competencia y porque tampoco se percibía
su importancia la ciudad no lo
necesitaba así que mientras en chicago
estaban apoyando impulsando y
construyendo nuevas infraestructuras
férreas en serveis los planes aún
continuaban ceñidos al papel todo era
más lento
para colmo llegó el año 1861 el año en
el que explotó la guerra civil en los
eeuu recordáis que hace un momento
comentamos que buena parte del comercio
de san luís estaba ligado a nueva
orleans ya los estados del sur pues el
problema es que al estallar la guerra
civil se cortaron los lazos comerciales
con esos estados de excepción istas
dejando por tanto sanluis sin su mayor
activo económico y encima al alcance del
bando rival así que en ese momento claro
se [ __ ] que está situada bastante más al
norte fue considerada como una plaza
mucho más segura motivo por el cual
cobró mucho protagonismo durante los
cuatro años que duró la guerra y también
durante la posguerra
[Música]
la guerra civil impulsó a chicago
respecto a san luis como la potencia
industrial de referencia lo que también
vino acompañado lógicamente de más
inversiones en infraestructuras y si
también de un enorme crecimiento
demográfico para 1890 chicago ya tenía
más del doble de población que san luis
ya había superado el millón de
habitantes y eso a pesar de que apenas
40 años antes no era más que un pueblo
grande de unos 30 mil habitantes
amigos a louis perdió su posición el
declive de su principal ruta comercial y
el desarrollo comparativamente menor del
ferrocarril hizo que poco a poco la
ciudad se fuera quedando atrás respecto
a las grandes urbes norteamericanas y
aunque esa luisi siguió creciendo con el
paso de los años ya nunca volvió a
brillar como antes porque recordad que
estamos hablando de la que era una de
las ciudades más importantes de los eeuu
una ciudad que estaba prácticamente al
mismo nivel que en nueva york'
ahora bien cuando vimos antes el gráfico
de la población lo que nos encontramos
es con un gran declive desde que los
años 50 la ciudad alcanzará su máximo
nivel de población qué demonios ocurrió
entonces que provocó una caída de casi
el 70 por ciento en el número de
habitantes que ha llevado a sanluis a
convertirse en una de las 10 ciudades
más peligrosas de todo el mundo
atentos
[Música]
el detroit 2.0 os lo decía al principio
del vídeo los dos caminos de san luis y
detroit se han parecido bastante y es
que una vez perdida la batalla contra
chicago casi que podríamos decir que el
siguiente rival fue detroit la entonces
joya de la industria del automóvil
norteamericana tenía competencia ya a
principios del siglo 20 san luís y sus
alrededores se habían convertido en la
segunda región de eeuu con mayor
producción automóviles justo por detrás
evidentemente de detroit de hecho se
dice que la primera gasolinera de todo
el país se puso en marcha aquí en san
luís y también se dice que en este sitio
es donde se produjo el primer accidente
de tráfico claro que yo no estoy muy
seguro de que parte de todo esto es
verdad o leyenda el caso es que la
industrialización hizo que ambas
ciudades recibieran una enorme cantidad
de inmigración desde el sur de los eeuu
especialmente de población afroamericana
la gran migración fue un fenómeno
migratorio masivo que movió a 6 millones
de afroamericanos desde los estados del
sur a a los estados del noreste medio
oeste y oeste del país las difíciles
condiciones económicas y la dura
segregación racial que se vivía en el
sur de eeuu hizo que muchos
afroamericanos quisieran buscar un
futuro mejor en las ciudades
industrializadas del norte entre esas
ciudades estuvo precisamente sanluis
[Música]
para los amigos parecía recobrar su
empuje la ciudad experimentó un boom
inmobiliario y en 1904 albergó incluso
la exposición universal y los juegos
olímpicos y los dos eventos el mismo año
y en la misma ciudad el problema es que
la urbe volvió a repetir prácticamente
los mismos errores de la segunda mitad
del siglo 19 falta de diversificación y
parálisis progresiva no había
prácticamente nada más que la industria
del automóvil y cuando ésta empezó a
tener problemas todo se vino abajo el
proceso fue exactamente el mismo que os
contamos en el caso de troy tenéis el
vídeo en la descripción la crisis amigos
azotó a la ciudad el paro se multiplicó
o la delincuencia se convirtió en algo
habitual y muchas personas de clase
media comenzaron a escapar a mudarse a
las afueras san luis comenzó a estar
dominada por edificios abandonados pozos
de marginalidad delincuencia y muchos
pero que muchos estupefacientes el
cóctel completo es precisamente por esto
que san luis es conocida como una de
droid 2.0
el segundo de troy del que muy poca
gente habla y que a día de hoy afronta
problemas casi tan graves como los de su
vecina ciudad norteña de michigan en
detroit de marca blanca que tiene un
futuro tan complicado como el original
una ciudad que un día fue una de las
grandes estrellas de la potencia
norteamericana y que hoy lucha por salir
adelante convertida en una de las
ciudades más peligrosas de todo el mundo
y llegados a este punto la pregunta es
podrá ser louis en hacer y volver a ser
un lugar próspero repleto de sueños de
personas que buscan mejorar sus vidas
tendrá una nueva ocasión esta ciudad
para florecer y recuperar la magia que
un día tuvo en fin no lo sabemos sólo el
tiempo nos lo podrá decir de momento
déjanos tu opinión por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
resulta interesante no olvidéis darle al
botón de like suscribiros a visual
político para estar al tanto de todas
nuestras novedades una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]